with me now national border patrol
council vice president art del coyo and
art uh what did you make of secretary
mayorkas's visit to the border today
you know it's just there's been so many
individuals that just continuously go
down there and visit they can visit
every day they can take their little
photo ops every day but unless they're
willing to change the policies and
realize what's happening our nation's
borders it's it's just cheap little
visits they mean nothing they absolutely
mean nothing this this administration
has managed to destroy everything that
the last administration has done and
it's going to take political will i i'm
truly saddened when i see this i'm
saddened that future generations are
going to be severely damaged
because of the lack of border security
policies from the current
individuals that are in charge right now
you know aren't uh we're running some
footage here and it just kind of struck
me uh to see him standing in front of
the wall or part of the wall and you
just kind of wonder like golly if they
had completed that how much how much
that might have helped what has become
an overwhelming situation for for you
folks
you know and it's not just the
completion of the wall it's bringing
back some of the policies that would
work at the end of the day the only
individuals that are
flourishing and love what this
administration is doing is the criminal
cartels that continue to line their
pockets each and every day by the
millions because of this
administration's lack of caring for the
border and caring for future generations
and just at the end of the day they they
don't care about americans lives all
right we heard the uh the secretary uh
almost boasting earlier in the week on
how often he has visited the border you
brought up the point that it feels more
like you're just simply checking a box
is he even asking the right questions is
there any sense of sincerity there
i don't see it and it's evident because
the flow of illegals continue to come in
this administration continues to create
that magnet now with you know getting
rid of title 42 it's just going to
create a much bigger flow coming in they
say they're going to put more agents out
there to help process when in reality
when you look at what they're saying
they're going to help
these individuals that are crossing
internet states get processed so they
can get released in the united states
faster that's how they're doing they
need to bring back policies that
actually work they need to start taking
care of our nation's borders and take
care of american citizens that's what
they're in those positions for to begin
with you know we had a full screen up as
we were going over some of the numbers
and what struck me is the 89 642 single
male adults versus just 7 000 families
you know i know a lot of folks are
fleeing persecution or dangerous
situations
uh you know
it just but it just seems overwhelming
uh it just
just hard to grasp that amount of single
males
month after month leaving their
countries to come to this country
correct and then you start looking at
the numbers of those that are getting
away because what these cartels are
doing in the human smuggling
organizations is they're they're
concentrating on one area making sure
that agents go to that spot now they
have to worry about processing
transporting and then many times
hospital watches and that's when they
start making their moves of bringing
individuals that have serious criminal
backgrounds in the united states and at
the same time push their illegal drugs
and that is being caused because this
administration and the leadership in
this administration refuses to see that
there's a problem going down there and
taking a couple of quick pictures that
means nothing real quick then art um
title 42 uh goes away
what what are you bracing for what do
you anticipate
well if you start looking at what title
42 has been helpful on and then you
start saying they're going to get rid of
it it is equivalent to handing the keys
to every american home's front door to
the drug cartels of mexico
wow
that's tough thank you so much art we
appreciate the work that you do down
there thank you hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe
right now